[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا انا راويه القاسم وهذه
العربيه 360 الخبر
[موسيقى]
انطلاق ونصف نهائي كاس العالم الارجنتين
تسعى لمقعد المباراه النهائيه على حساب
كرواتيا
ايران تعمق عزلتها بتورطها بحرب اوكرانيا
وكيابا تحذرها من عواقب اكبر بكثير من
الفوائد
التايمز البريطانيه تكشف عن مشاركه
البحريه في عمليات سريه باوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
وفي القضايا السياسيه التي شغلت مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعيه تتابعونا ايضا
بعد الانهيار الكبير لبورصه عملات اف تي
اكس مؤسسها قيد الاعتقال ومتهم بالاحتلال
على المستثمرين
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم يقفوا المنتخب الكرواتي وقائده
المخضرم لوكا مودريتش بين النجم
الارجنتيني ليونيل ميسي وفرصته الاخيره
لمنح بلاده لقبها الاول منذ عام
1986 بين ان نجم ريال مدريد لوكا مودريتش
ورغم سنوات التي تجاوزت السبعه وثلاثين
عاما استطاع ان يقود منتخبه كرواتيا الى
نصف النهائي ليواجهها منتخب مصر
امنا في تجاوز عقبه التانجو والوصول الى
النهائي للمره الثانيه في تاريخ بلاده بعد
ما فعلها في مونديال روسيا العام 2018
بعد حيث فازت الارجنتين مرتين وانتصرت
كرواتيا مرتين وتعادلات مره واحده
في مثل هذا الوقت من يوم غد سيكون المنتخب
المغربي على موعد مع التاريخ بلقاء فرنسا
في نصف نهائي كاس العالم مدرب المنتخب
المغربي وليد الركراكي يبدو مفعنا بالحماس
والثقه قبل خوض المواجهه المرتقبه امام
فرنسا حامله لقب النسخه الاخيره من
البطوله
قال خلال مؤتمر صحفي اليوم انه بالوصول
الى قبل النهائي يجب ان تكون متعطشا خاصه
وان الوصول لهذا الدور ليس متاحا للجميع
واضاف مدرب المنتخب المغربي ان فريقه لديه
رغبه بان يضع افريقيا على قمه العالم وهي
ستكون المهمه يوم غد رغم الثقه هذه اكد
الركراكي ان كل الترجيحات تصب في مصلحه
فرنسا لكن المنتخب المغربي لديه ثقه كبيره
بالنفس وقال انه ربما تعتبر الث فنونا لكن
القليل من الجنون ليس سيئا وليد الركراك
شدد على انه يطمح للمزيد من الانجازات
ليكون مصدر الهاما للاجيال القادمه
لذلك كما قلت في بدايه المسابقه نحلم
بالفوز بكاس العالم وكل ما تقدمنا اكثر
اقتربنا من حلمنا لذلك غدا سنكافح للمضيما
نحن واثقون حتى لو صارت كل التوقعات ضدنا
ربما نكون مجانين ولكن من الجيد ان تكون
مجنونه
مباراه الغد تشمل مباريات داخل المباراه
اي تنافسن بين اللاعبين في المنتخبين ربما
يكون الابرز فيها تواجه كيليان مبابي
واشرف حكيمي اللاعبان يرتبطان بصداقه قويه
في باريس سان جيرمان لكن مدرب المنتخب
المغربي قال انه لن يضع خطه استثنائيه او
طريقه لايقاف لاعب واحد فبحسبره اكيد يضم
المنتخب الفرنسي اداء جماعيا رائعا كما
انه يضم لاعبينا بامكانهم تشكيل خطوره على
المنتخب المغربي وفيما يتعلق بمواجهه
حكيمي و مبابي قال ركراك انه لن يقدم
نصائح معينه لحكيم لان اللاعب المغربي
يعرف زميله اكثر ويتدرب معه بشكل يومي في
باريس اثناء وجودهما معا لكن هذا الامر لا
يعني ان يقدم احدهما هديه للاخر خلال
حتى
[موسيقى]
تكتيكيه معينه لمواجهه كليان مبابي لسوء
الحظ بالنسبه لنا هناك اكثر من مجرد كليا
فرنسا لديها لاعبون جيدون اخرون جريزمان
في قمه مستواه ويلعب بشكل جيد بين الخطوط
وعثمان ديمبلي هو ايضا مكمل مثالي لمباقي
في الجناح الاخر اذا ركزنا فقط على مبابي
فسيكون هذا خطا كبيرا اشرف حكيمي هو احد
افضل اللاعبين في العالم لذلك ستكون
مبارزه كبيره بين الاثنين انهم ابطال
العالم مع لاعبين من الطراز العالمي
وسيحققون ذلك بكل ما لديهم نحن بحاجه الى
التركيز على ما يمكننا القيام به لاحداث
مشاكل فرنسا
نبقى مع كيليان مبابي واشرف حكيمي مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي اعاده نشره مقطع مصور
للاعبين في يناير من العام الجاري اثناء
زياره فريق باريس سان جيرمان للعاصمه
القطريه حينها زار اللاعبان ملعب المدينه
التعليميه بقيق قال حينها ان الملعب
سيستضيف مباراه فرنسا وتونس بدوري
المجموعات ولاحقا ستلتقي فرنسا والمغرب
وان فرنسا ستفوز ومنذ انتقال حكيمي الى
باريس سان جيرمان قبل موسمين توطدت
العلاقه مع بابيت فعاده ما يظهر اللاعبان
معا في التدريبات وايضا مرات كثيره خارج
الملعب غدا سيكون اللاعبان متنافسين على
ارض الملعب عندما يلتقي منتخبات المغرب
وفرنسا في نصف نهائي مونديال قطر نشير
اخيرا الى ان تتوقع بابي بشان مواجهه
فرنسا وتونس لم يكن صحيحا لان تونس فازت
حينها فهل سي متوقعه هذه المره ام سيخب
مجددا غدا سنعرف النتيجه
التعليميه الذي يتسع ل 40 الف مشجع فرنسا
وتونس ستلعبان هنا سنفوز ثم سنلتقي مع
المغرب
وسيكون هدفي تدمير صديق اشرف ساحطمه
الامر سيكسر قلبه ولكن هذه الكره يجب ان
يدمر
وسيكون احد منتخبين الارجنتين او كرواتيا
نبدا مع كرواتيا وصيفه النسخه السابقه هذا
المنتخب اعتاد على لعب اشواط اضافيه في
المراحل الاقصائيه وصولا الى النهائي كما
حدث في النسخه الاخيره وهو ما تكرر في هذه
البطوله امام كل من اليابان والبرازيل طول
مدى المباريات جعل المحللين يتساءلون عما
اذا كانت خبره المباريات الطويله ستساعد
كرواتيا امس ستؤدي لارهاق لاعبيها
وستعتمد كرواتيا بشكل كبير على قائدها
لوكا مودريتش القادر على الاحتفاظ بالكره
وصنع الهجمات الخطيره باعتباره العقل
المدبر من الناحيه الهجوميه لكرواتيا على
الجانب الاخر تبين او يبين ظهور ليونيل
ميسي كصانع للالعاب
ماذا نجعته خاصه خلال تمريرته التي جاء
منها هدف الارجنتين الوحيد امامه هولندا
في المباراه الماضيه
نقطه النقص الوحيده في منتخب التانجو ربما
هي في عدم وجود مهاجم صريح من الطراز
العالمي على خلاف كرواتيا واذا كانت الفرص
متقاربه على الورق تتفوق الارجنتين بشكل
واضح فهي ااا في المدرجات حيث يتوقع ان
يساندها على الاقل اربعين الف ارجنتينيه
اضافه لمحبي هذا المنتخب من مختلف الدول
العالم
والى الدوحه مع موفد العربيه ليث بزاري
اهلا بك ليث
يعني انت تتواجد امام ملعب لوسي الاستاذ
لوسيل بالدوحه
والمباراه بدات الاجواء من عندك والحماس
الارجنتيني لان هناك الكثير من الجماهير
الارجنتينيه التي توافدت الى العاصمه
القطريه لتشجيع منتخبها
نعم راويه اعتذر للبرازيل بعرفك بتحب
البرازيل وبتشجع منتخب البلد ولكن هنا في
هذا ستاد خلفي ملعب الوسيل يوجد 88,000
1699 شخص الذين يحضرون هذه المباراه هنا
في ملعب الاستاذ شمال الدوحه ولكن الكثير
من حولي لم يحصلوا على تذكره ويحاولون
شراء تذاكر هنا على بوابه الملعب كهذه
السيده التي اتت من غواتيمالا
تقول اذا ترجمه حرفيا اتمنى من الله ان
احصل على تذكره لكي اشجع المنتخب
الارجنتيني كما نشاهد هي ترتدي اللونين
الازرق والابيض والكثير من مثلها هنا اتوا
من مناطق مختلفه ليس فقط من الارجنتين
شاهدنا الكثير من امريكا اللاتينيه الذين
دخلوا اجراءات السنيوره شكرا الذين دخلوا
من هذه البوابه الى الى داخل استوديو ومن
ثم الكثير منهم يعني دخلوا بحماس شديد لم
اتوقع ولم اشاهد قبل ذلك راويه العديد من
المشجعين الذين اتوا من جميع انحاء العالم
وهم طبعا فرحين ويهتفون ويحملون طاقه
كبيره طاقه ايجابيه للوصول هذا الملعب الى
هذه الى هذا ستاد لمتابعه المباراه بين
الفريقين
سمعنا عن جسر جوي بيننا المغرب والدوحه
لنقل همم مشجعين المغربيين لمؤازره
منتخبهم لمست على الارض
فعليا ازديا باعداد المشجعين للمنتخب
المغربي اللي هن ليسوا فقط طبعا من
الجاليه المغربيه انما ايضا كل العرب
سوف اعطيك تفاصيل اكثر ولكن نسمع تصفيق
كبير داخل الملعب لا ادري اذا كان هذا
هدفا او لا نعم شاهدنا الكثير من المغاربه
الذين اتوا 16 طائره في يوم من الايام
عندما كانت المباراه في المدينه التعليميه
اديوكيشن سيتي حضرت 16 طائره من مطار محمد
الخامس هناك في كازابلانكا او الدار
البيضاء الى هنا الدوحه الكثير من
المشجعين المغاربه اتوا في ساعات بعد
الظهر وصلوا الى المطار مباشره الى
المباراه ومن ثم يعودون في ساعات الصباح
الباكر لاستقلال هذه الطائره والعوده الى
مره اخرى الى المغرب ولا استبعد ذلك
الكثير شهدنا الكثير في مناطق هتاف كبير
لا ادري اذا كان هدفا مره اخرى
ههه
نعم ههه فالكثير منهم ما وصلوا وشاهدنا
ذلك وصلنا ذلك في مشاري بمشيرب منطقه من
المناطق تنبض بالحياه هنا في الدوحه كانت
الالوان حمراء وخضراء العالم المغربي كان
في اي في كل في كل الامكنه كذلك سوق واقف
وشاهدنا حتى ساعات الفجر عندما ربحت
المغرب على البرتغال المباراه كيف كانت
الهدافات والتجمعات
والاهازيج والاغاني والزغاريد اذا سحب
التعبير المغربيه هناك في سوق واقف
والكثير منهم واعين المغاربه اليوم ما
ننسى راويه على هذه المباراه الذي
مغاربه ان شاء الله ههه
انا وصلت اهو من المانيا من دورتموند من
المانيا اليوم اليوم لا ماشي اليوم
يا الله يا الله
ان شاء الله ان شاء الله ان شاء الله
نتابع على كل حال اعين اعين المغرب
نعم هذا ما يحدث احيانا في المباشر رابع
باعتذر ولكن الكثير من المشجعين المغاربه
اليوم اعينهم على هذه المباراه كي يعرفوا
من سيواجه المنتخب المغربي اذا فاز
بالمباراه على المنتخب الفرنسي والمغرب
شكرا جزيلا لك يا ليث بازاري موفد العربيه
المحبوب من كل الجماهير من الدوحه شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
تتابعونا بعد الفاصل
القضاء الفرنسي دين ثمانيه متهمين في هجوم
نيس عام 2016
[موسيقى]
وقال انه يجب محاسبتها على تورطها في
الحرب
اما الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون فقال
ان الضربات الجويه الروسيه الغرض الوحيد
منها هو تقويض مقاومه الشعب الاوكراني
على المقاومه ولسماحي لاوكرانيا بالصمود
خلال هذا الشتاء اردنا ان ننظم معا هذا
المؤتمر واردنا ان تكون النتائج ملموسه
هذه الضربات الجويه التي تستهدف علنا
السكان الاوكرانيين والبنيه التحتيه التي
اعترفت روسيا بان الغرض الوحيد منها هو
تقويض مقاومه الشعب الاوكراني ترقى الى
جرائم حرب وتنتهي دون ادنى شك اهم المبادئ
الاساسيه للقانون الانسانيه هذه الاعمال
غير مقبوله ولن تبقى دون عقاب اريد ان
اكون واضحا في هذا السياق الامر متروك
لاوكرانيا ضحيه العدوان قرار بشان شروط
السلام العادل والمستدام
سباق اعلنت وزيره الخارجيه الفرنسيه
كاترين كلونا ان المؤتمر الدولي الذي
استضافته باريس لدعم اوكرانيا اتاح جمعه
عباد بحوالي مليار يورو لمساعده السكان في
تحمل فصل الشتاء في بعد ان ضربت روسيا
معظم اشاهد الطاقه في البلاد واوضحت كلنا
ان من اصل مبلغ المليار يورو سيخص نحو
415 مليونا لقطاعات طاقه و25 مليون للمياه
و38 مليون للغذاء و17 مليون للصحه و22
مليونا لوسائل النقل في ما لم يتم تقسيم
المبلغ المتبقي
وينضم الينا من باريس مراسل العربيه حسين
قنيبر اهلا بك حسين معنا في النشره يعني
هل من تفاصيل اكثر حول هذا المؤتمر وما
قدمه يعني ذكرنا تقسيم هذه المبالغ بين
المياه والطاقه وغيرها هل من تفاصيل اخرى
مساء الخير اولا كاترين كولونات قالت ان
هذه المبالغ هي مبالغ اوليه مرشحه لان
تتطور لان مساعدات اضافيه قد تقدم الى
الشعب الاكراني من خلال منظمات دوليه اذكر
بان الذين حضروا المؤتمر الدولي في باريس
اليوم وهو واحد من مؤتمرين عقده عقد مؤتمر
دولي من التاسعه صباحا حتى الثانيه من بعد
الظهر شاركت فيه 48 دوله واربع وعشرون
منظمه دوليه كما عقد بعض ظهر مؤتمر ثنائي
فرنسي اكثر يعني بالنسبه لهذا المؤتمر
الدولي الذي عقد صباحا تركز مطالب
اوكرانيا خلاله على الثلاثي مساء الى
رئيسيه اولا المساله المتعلقه بفقدان
الكهرباء نتيجه استهداف الضربات الروسيه
لمعظم المحطات النوويه السلميه التي تساعد
على انتاج الكهرباء ما ادى الى حاجتنا
الكبيره قال الرئيس زرنسكي في كلمته عبر
الفيديو امام المؤتمرين ادى الى حاجتنا
للغاز نحتاج خلال فصل الشتاء الى ملياري
متر مكعب من الغاز كما نحتاجه الى نظام
الدفاع جوي يحمينا حذر الرئيس الاوكراني
وهذا كان لافتا جدا حذر المؤتمرين من انه
ما لم يساعد الاوكرانيون في تامين الطاقه
خلال الشتاء فان هذا سيؤدي الى موجاتي
لجوء كثيفه نحو الدول الاوروبيه اتمنى ان
تكون هناك قرارات ملموسه والامر بين
ايديكم كما قال الرئيس الاوكراني بالعوده
الى لغه الارقام كما ذكرت تماما 415 مليون
ستدرس تحديدا لقطاع الطاقه بشقائه
الكهرباء والتدفئه ولن اكرر الارقام
الاخرى التي ذكرتها لكنني اشير الى ان
نعم يا تعتبر ان الحاجه الملحه حاليا هي
متعلقه تحديدا بقطاعات الصحه والمياه
والنقل والمواد الغذائيه بشكل اساسي
واخيرا في هذا المجال تحديدا المؤتمر
الثاني الذي انعقد بعض الظهر الفرنسي
الاوكراني شاركت فيه 700 شركه فرنسيه قدمت
خبراتها وعرضت خدماتها لاعاده اعمار
اوكرانيا على المدى البعيد والدعم
الاقتصاد الاوكراني راويه
حسيني يعني بعد قليل سيكون لدينا ملف حول
العقوبات التي فرضتها بريطانيا على كل من
روسيا وايران وتحديدا ايران لتواطؤها مع
روسيا بارسال المسيارات الايرانيه
لاستعمالها ضد المدنيين الاوكرانيين وهو
فحوى تصريح كان مع كلي رئيس وزراء
اوكرانيا وايضا فرنسا التي يعني كل
الاطراف تقريبا تحمل ايران مسؤوليه
التواطقها مع روسيا
نعم منذ افتتاح المؤتمر صباح اليوم التطرق
الرئيس الاوكراني يازلنسكي خلال كلمته عبر
شاشه فيديو امام المؤتمرين تطرق الى هذه
النقطه وقال ان المسيرات الايرانيه تمارس
ما اسماه بالترهيب من هنا وخلال السؤال
طرحته على كل من رئيس الوزراء الاوكراني
ووزيره الخارجيه الفرنسيه
الى هذه النقطه وزيره الخارجيه الفرنسيه
عندما سالتها عن اسباب توقف الاتصالات
التي كانت سابقا منتظمه بين فرنسا وايران
عن اسباب توقفها منذ حوالي شهرين لم يعد
وزراء الخارجيه يتواصلان هاتفيا بشكل
منتظم كما كان يحصل سابقا منذ فتره
لودريان كوازير للخارجيه في فرنسا سابقا
ثم مع كاترين كولونات توقفت الاتصالات
المنتظمه مع نظيرها حسين امير عبد الله
هيان نظيرها الايراني كما توقفت الاتصالات
التي كانت تحصل بشكل متفرق بين نكره
ورئيسي قالت لنا وزيره الخارجيه الفرنسيه
ردا على اسباب توقف الاتصالات ان ما تقوم
به ايران هو سياسه اخذرها ان مهمتنا في
علاقات طبيعيه معها كانت ستكون اسهل بكثير
لو لم تعمل الى سياسه اخذ الرهائن هناك
اذكر قالت كلنا هناك سبع رعاء فرنسيين
موقوفين حاليا في ايران كما ان السلطات
الايرانيه تقوم بما اثمته كولونا عمليات
القمع الوحشي ضد المتظاهرين وهي عمليات
قمعا غير مبرره وغير مقبوله كما قالت ان
فرنسا كانت مضطره لاستدعاء القائم باعمال
ايران اكثر من مره بسبب تصرف هذا البلد
اما رئيس الوزراء الاوكراني فقال ان
المسيرات الايرانيه تساهم في قتل
الاوكرانيين المئات من الاوكرانيين قتلوا
بسبب المسيرات الايرانيه من هنا قال دونيز
اشغال فانا ايران هي شركه في جرائم الحرب
الروسيه التي يجب ان يحاسب مرتكبها وان
يتحمل مسؤولي لان ما يقومون به يرقه الى
مستوى جرائم اباده ضد الشعب الاوكراني حسب
التعبير الحرفي لرئيس وزراء هذا البلد
راويه شكرا جزيلا لك حسين قنيبر مراسل
العربيه من باريس
[موسيقى]
يوما بعد يوم تزداد وعزله ايران الدوليه
بطورطها في حرب اوكرانيا 9 طهران
للاستفاده من مد موسكو بالمسيرات غير
انكاف قالت صراحه ان عواقب دعم تهران
للحرب على كياف ستكون اكبر بكثير من فوائد
تعاونها مع موسكو رئيس الوزراء الاوكراني
دينيس شمايل شدد على ضروره محاسبه ايران
على تورطها في الازمه الاوكرانيه وتواطئها
في جرائم حرب روسيا اما المتحدث باسمي
وزاره الخارجيه الاوكرانيه اوليك
نيكولينكو اكد ان بلاده هو خلال اجتماعها
مع الجانب الايراني قدمت ادله كافيه على
امتداد روسيا باسلحه ايرانيه وقال
نيكولينكو لدينا مئات الوقائع المسجله عن
قصف في اراضي اوكرانيه شرقا وجنوبا بواسطه
طائرات مسيره ايرانيه كل هذه التصريحات
يبدو انها لم تجد اذان صاغيه حتى من قبل
موجودين في ذلك الاجتماع بمن فيهم الجانب
الايراني الذي انكر كل ذلك لان وزير
الدفاع الايراني محمد رضا الشياني نفى
نفيقاتي عن ان اوكرانيا قدمت اي برهان
ولبريطانيا رايه يتفق مع اوكرانيا حيث وصف
وزير الخارجيه البريطاني جينز لافلي صفقات
ايران وروسيا بانها دنيئه وتهدد الامن
العالمي وقال اننا سنحاسب التحالف اليائس
لايران وروسيا فالهجوم الروسيه على المدن
والمدنيين الامبرياء لن يمر بلا رد خاصه
وان طهران باتت اكبر الداعمين العسكريين
لمسكو وبعد عقوبات اوروبا اعلنت بريطانيا
فرده قيود على اثني عشر قائده عسكريه
روسيا متورطين في ضربات صاروخيه استهدفت
مدن اوكرانيا وكذلك على رجال اعمال
ايرانيين متورتين في انتاجه وتوريدي
طائرات مسيره عسكريه استخدم في الحشمتها
سته الاف مدنيه الاوكرانيا لقوا حتفهم منذ
بدايه الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا جراء
الضربات الصاروخيه والمدفعيه الروسيه
حصيله ثقيله دفعت بريطانيا مره جديده الى
اصدار عقوبات شملت 12 قائدا بارزا في
الجيش الروسي بينهم قائد لوحده توصل تحقيق
الى ان الوحده مسؤوله عن برمجه وتوجيه
الصواريخ الروسيه ديهاكات خطيره للقانون
الانساني الدولي حسب البيان الذي اكد على
ضروره محاسبه المسؤولين عن هذه الهجمه
ايران مشموله بالعقوبه الجديده التي طالت
شركه مادو الايرانيه ومديرها يوسف ابو
طالبي والمسؤوله بمنظمه الجهاد للاكتفاء
الذاتي والبحوث التابعه للحرس الثوري عبد
الله محرابي ورئيس منظمه الصناعه الجويه
الايرانيه افشين خواجا فرد
الخارجيه البريطانيه اكدت ان الطائرات
المسيره ايرانيه الصنع
الرئيسيه في الهجمات الروسيه على المدنيين
باوكرانيا
غير مقبوله على سبيل المثال توفير مسيله
عسكريه والتي يتم استخدامها في المدنيين
والبنيه التحتيه المدنيه من قبل روسيا في
اوكرانيا لقد فرضنا عقوبات على المطورطين
في ذلك
واشار البيان الى ان معلومات اصدرتها
الولايه المتحده مؤخرا تظهر ان ايران
اصبحت احد اكبر الداعمين العسكريين لروسيا
وان طهران ارسلت مئات الطائرات المسيره
الى روسيا في انتهاك الالتزاماتها
القانونيه الدوليه
اهلا بك معنا دكتور حسان يعني ما مدى
تاثير هذه العقوبات اليوم على ايران خاصه
عقوبات منذ اكثر من اربعين عاما واصلا
سلاح العقبات في علاج جد ان كان فعالا او
لا لماذا الاصرار الاوروبي على فرض عقوبات
ان كان على ايران وان كان على روسيا
نعم بعد التحيه من خلالك لكل فريق العربيه
وعموما المشاهدين يعني يوم فقط بعد ما
تحدثت الخارجيه الفرنسيه عن جهود اوروبيه
سوف تقودها فرنسا لمضاعفه عقوبات على
ايران بحكم ما يجري في الداخل الايراني
وابو حكم كذلك تسليم مسيرات نفذها ايران
قطعا على امتداد فتره طويله ولكن فيما بعد
اعترفت وقالت ان سلمت ما قبل العمليه
العسكريه اين قبل 24 فبراير الماضي كما
قلت ان وتيره العقوبات تسارع خاصه ان نقول
خاصه ان هناك دول كانت تتميز باليونه في
التعامل مع الجنب الايراني على غرار ايران
سافران التي كانت دائما تريد ان تكون هي
الوسيط ولكن يبدو حتى من حديث الوزيره
الخارجيه الفرنسيه اليوم ان النظره
الفرنسيه بدات تتغير تجاه ايران بدات
تتغير بحكم اثنين ربما العام الاول هو
بيجري في الداخل الايراني لان النظام
اهترى حقيقه ولم يبقى في عمره الا بعض
القليل حذف متابعين بحكم ممكن في هذه
المره وحتى على خلاف ان حدث ممكن في 2019
ان الاحتجاجات تستمر على امتداد ممكن اشهر
اصبحت يعني نتحدث عن شهرين ثلاثه وما زال
الشعب الايراني يقاوم هذا النظام
الاستبداد والشمول والنقطه الثانيه واللب
ما هي الاهم بالنسبه لاوروبا لنقل الحقيقه
هي التعاون الايراني مع جيني بالروسي في
المسائل العسكريه والدخول ايران بصفه غير
مباشره في هذه العمليه العسكريه في
اوكرانيا ربما هذا الذي افاضى القطره التي
افاضت الاكس الكاس بالنسبه للاوروبيين لان
الاوروبيين لن يتسامحوا اطلاقا مع الجنب
الايراني في اي قطعه سلاح سوف
لجانب الروسي في هذه العمليه العسكريه
لذلك جاءت هذه العقوبات شملت كما تفضلت
نعم نعم شملت عدت رجال اعمال ايرانيين
وايضا
روس وعسكريين فعليا ما تصورت لي في حال
سيناري ولو كان تم الاتفاق بين ايران
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه والاوروبيين
وعادت ايران الى الاتفاق النووي هل كانت
ايران لتدعم روسيا بالمسيرات الايرانيه
لو كان هناك حصل الدفاع في ذلك المره تكون
الطويل من محادثه فيينا
ههه
لن اعتقد ان ايران كانت تتجرا على مثل هذه
الخطوه ولكن هذه الخطوه تدل ربما دلالتها
الاكبر هي ان ايران تنصلت بالكامل وربما
طويه صفحه الاتفاق النووي لذلك ذهاب ايران
والتعاون العسكري مع الجنوب الروسي يعني
ان ايران لم تعد تعول لا على فيينا وعلى
المحادثات ولا حتى العوده الى اتفاق ربما
هذا اكبر استنتاج يمكن استنتاج حقيقتها
شكرا جزيلا لك الدكتور حسن القبلي الباحث
في الاقتصاد السياسي حدثنا من باريس
[موسيقى]
الجيش البريطاني نفذ عمليات سريه في
اوكرانيا حسبما كشف جنرال بريطاني لصحيفه
المسؤول البريطاني قال للصحيفه ان وحدات
المارينز الملكيه وهي وحدات النخبه في
البحريه البريطانيه في عمليات سريه شديده
الحساسيه وتنطوي على مستوى عال من المخاطر
العسكريه والسياسيه الضابط اوضح انه تم
ارسال 350 من مشاهده البحريه من وحده
النخبه 45 لمرافقه الدبلوماسيين من
السفاره البريطانيه في وقت سابقا من
العامه بينما كانت القوات الروسيه تحشد
للهجوم على اوكرانيا وفي وقت لاحقا عادت
وحده النخبه الى العاصمه الاوكرانيه في
ابريلا لضمان امن السفاره عندما كانت
المملكه المتحده تعيد ترتيب تمثيل
هديبلوماسي بعد انسحاب القوات الروسيه من
محيطك في ذلك الوقت اقرت وزاره الدفاع في
لندن بارسال قوات كوماندوز حمايه افراد
السفاره لكنها قالت ان عددهم لا يتجاوز 30
جنديا ليتبين اللاحقا ان العدد 10 اضعاف
الرقم المعلن ويعد الاعلان من قبل القائد
السابق روبرت ماغوان اول ضابط كبير يعترف
بمشاركه القوات البريطانيه في عمليات خاصه
في اوكرانيا واشار الى ان الجنود الذين تم
نشرهم تم ارسالهم من شمال لاجراء اجلاء
البعثه الدبلوماسيه فيكاف الى بولندا
[موسيقى]
اذنت محكمه فرنسيه ثمانيه اشخاص متهمين
بالتورد في هجوم شاحنات نيس عام 2016
حينها عن مقتل 86 شخصا كانوا يحتفلون
بالعيد الوطني الفرنسي في مدينه نيسا
المطله على شاطئ اريفيرا الفرنسيه
[موسيقى]
علقت الهيئه العليا المستقله للانتخابات
في تونس عمليات الاقتراع في عدد من
الدوائر الانتخابيه في دول الاوروبيه
ويعود السبب بحسب السفاره التونسيه في
بريطانيا نظرا لعدم وجود مترشحين مقبولين
للانتخابات التشريعيه المقرر اجرائها هذا
الشهر على ان يتم سد الشهور بمجلس نواب في
فتره اللاحقه السفاره فان الهيئه لم تفتح
مكاتب الاقتراع في كل من برمنجام ومانشستر
وادم برودبا الايام الخمسه عشر والسادس
عشر والسابعه عشر من ديسمبر كما واشار
ماهر الجديده نائب رئيس هيئه الانتخابات
الى ان سبعه من اصل 10 مقاعد متعلقه
بالخارج شاغره مؤكدا ان سدها سيكون عبر
طريقتين احداهما تنظيم انتخابات جزئيه مع
تعديل القانوني الانتخابي اما الطريقه
الثانيه هي اتخاذ مجلس نواب الشعب
باعتباره مؤسسه السياديه قرا بيسد الشهور
او الابقاء على تشكيله البرلمان على حالها
[موسيقى]
اعتقال مؤسس اف تي اكس بتهمه الاحتلال على
المستثمرين تابعونا بعد الفاصل
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد بتهمه الاحتلال على
المستثمرين القات شرطه جزر البهاما القبض
على مالك منصه العملات
جلسه استماع في الكونجرس بشان التحقيق في
القضيه ليد لي كل من الموجودين بشهادته في
مجلس النواب لتحقيق في انهيار البورصه
الذي افلس هذه الشركه وكان من بينهم
الرئيس التنفيذي الجديد المعين من قبل
المحكمه
جنراي الثالث الذي قال ان المستثمرين يجب
ان يضعوا اشاره حمراء كبيره حول هذه
الشركه التي تبددت بسبب عدم وجود اي ضوابط
داخليه
وقال متحدث باسم لجنه الاوراق الماليه
والبورصات القبرصيه انهم يخططون لتمديد
تعليق ترخيص اف تي اكس وسيمتون في هذا
القرار الذي يناقشونه الاسبوع المقبل
مؤكدا ان اللجنه ستتخذ جميع الاجراءات
اللازمه لحمايه مصالح المستثمرين
الاوروبيين في افتئاسه وتعمل بشكل وثيق مع
المسؤولين في الولايات المتحده بموجب
الفصل الحادي عشر
خلال 24 ساعه انهارت ثروه الشاب الثلاثيني
سان باكمان فرايدا مؤسس بورصه العملات
المشفره اف تي اكس بنحو 94% في نوفمبر
الماضي رقم كارثي ادخل منصه التداول
ومؤسسها من اضيق ابواب التاريخ باعتباره
اكبر انخفاض تم التسجيله على الاطلاق في
مؤشر بلومبرج للملياردوراته وبين عشيه
وضحاها وبعد ان ترك باتمان اكثر من مليون
موده حاجزين عن سحب اموالهم يبدو ان غضبهم
لجم قليلا مع نبا اعتقال شرطه جزر قلبها
لمؤسس من الصعب واكد المدعي العام
الامريكي للمنطقه الجنوبيه نيويوركانيا
وليامز الاعتقال وقال ان الخطوه اتخذت
بناء على طلب من الحكومه الامريكيه واضاف
ان لائحه التهام المقدمه ستكشف في الوقت
المناسب
[موسيقى]
ذاك الشاب الذي كان ينظر اليه على انه حصن
امين بات منبوزا بعد ان عانت شركته من
ازمه سيوله وتقدمت بطلب للافلاسه وحصل
الافلاس بعد تعثر منصه تداول العمله في
جمع المليارات لدرء لانهيار بعد ان سارع
المتداولون لسحب سته مليارات دولار منها
خلال 72 ساعه فقط اثر علمهم بعمليه احتلال
انهيار امبراطوريه افتيا اكس يرجعهم
محللون بسبب الاختفاء المفاجئ للاموال
علما بان باتمان حول سرا 10 مليارات دولار
من اموال العملاء من اف تي اكس الى الميده
تزامنا مع اختفاء اكثر من مليار دولار من
اموال العملاء وفي شهاده مكتوبه قال
الرئيس التنفيذي الجديد لشركه اف تي اكس
المعين من قبل المحكمه جونراي الثالث ان
تبدد من الصلاه لم يكن الا بسبب التركيز
المطلق للسيطره في ايدي مجموعه صغيره جدا
من الافراد غير المتمارسين وليسوا اصحاب
مخبره مضيفا ان بنك مان سمح لشركه ابحاث
الاميدا باقتراضي اموال من بورصه العملات
المشفره بلا اي قيود فعله
[موسيقى]
وانضم الينا من واشنطن المكاتب والمحلل
السياسي ايهاب عباس اهلا بك سيد ايهاب
يعني انهيار شركه اف تي اكس واعتقال
مؤسسها هل يمكن وكيف يمكن تعويض المتضررين
الذين يمتلكون اموال على هذه المنصه حسب
القانون الامريكي
اهلا بحضرتك واهلا بكل المشاهدين طب طبعا
شركه اف تي اكس وهمم رئيسها اا بنكمان قام
بعمليه
اشهار الافلاس طبقا للفصل الحادي عشر من
قانون الافلاس الامريكي والذي يقضي بحمايه
الشركات المفلسه امام مطالبات ال- همم
الدائنين وبالتالي هذه ستكون هي المشكله
الكبيره التي ستواجه كل من وضع اموالا في
هذه الشركه واستثمرها بشكل او باخر لعده
اسباب بسبب الاول ان اا بنك من اليوم اصبح
محمنيا بقانون الافلاس من مساله التعويضات
التي
ستطالتين بالاضافه الى ان مساله التصفيه
الشركه وتعيين المحامي الجديد رئيسا
للشركه من قبل الاداره الامريكيه او
الحكومه الامريكيه همم يتخذ وقتا طويلا
يعني ربما سنوات حتى يتم حصر الاصول
والاموال وكيف سيتم التعويض الى اخره
وبالتالي ستكون هناك كلاب كبيره
للمستثمرين الذين استثمروا في هذه الشركه
خاصه صغار المستثمرين اتحدث عن
الاستثمارات اقل من مئه الف دولار سيكون
لديهم مشكلات كبيره لان هذه الاستثمارات
همم يعني تقريبا ذهبت هباءا حتى الان
قلت بانك من سيكون محمي بحسب قانون
الافلاس ماذا يعني
ذلك ولل الناس يعني تت
بخر حتى اللحظه هذه هي الحقيقه الموجوده
امامنا لكن هذا لا يعني انه لن يكون هناك
تعويضات سيتم همم طبعا بيع الشركه وحصر
اصولها والممتلكات الموجوده ويتم التعويض
بنسب مختلفه طبقا لكل همم مبلغ تم وضعه من
قبل المستثمر يعني لن يحصل كل شخص على
كامل ما استثمره في اطار هذه الشركه هذا
جانب الجانب الاخر اتهام التي وجهت اليوم
في لائحه الاتهام لبان كمان او التي من
المنتظر ان توجه بشكل رسمي من مقاطعه
مقاطعه الجنوبيه في نيويورك هي كلها تتعلق
بالاحتيال والتامر بالاحتلال في الاوراق
الماليه
والمصب وجرائم متعلقه بغسل الاموال يعني
من الممكن ان يسجن الى مدى الحياه هذا
الشخص يعني كمان
وللاسف الشديد التعويضات يعني الحكومه لم
تدفع من جيبها بها الامريكيه تعويضات
لهؤلاء الذين خسروا اموالهم بالاضافه الى
نقطه مهمه جدا ان الاستث في الديجيتال
كوينز او العملات المشفره الرقميه
واستثمار وهمي في نهايه المطاف وهذا ما
يتضح اليوم سوق الامارات المشفره بعد
اعلان اف تي اكس انهيارها وافلاسها خسرت
عشرات المليارات وربما مئات المليارات من
الدولارات لان القيمه السوقيه للعملات
المشفره كانت تجاوزت التريليون دولار بعد
اعلان الافلاس بايام قليله جدا اصبحت اقل
من 850 مليون ملياردو شكرا جزيلا لك على
هذه المعلومات
الكاتب هو المحلل السياسي
[موسيقى]
من امسك المليار دار الامريكي الماسك في
زمام تويتر حتى بدا وكانه يخص اجنحه
العصفور الازرق ليفقد مع قراراته شيئا
فشيئا كل من كان يختار تلك المنصه
لاستخدامها اجراءات صادمه لم تتوقف بمجازر
التسريحات الجماعيه ونسف عدد الموظفين الى
النصف بل بات الى الثلثين ومع هذه
التغييرات يرمي المنتقدون بسهامهم نحو مصر
والسبب انا ماسك يتراجعوا عن الجهود
الهادفه لجعل موقع التواصل الاجتماعي
مكانا اكثر تحضرا وامانا صحيفه واشنطن
بوست اكدت ان المنصه الزرقاء اعلنت حلا
مجلس الثقه والامان الخاص بالشركه خطوه
يراها منتقدون على انها مثال اخر قد يجعل
التطبيق مهجرا فهي ببساطه صغيره لا تنظر
بالخير
التي اوضحت ان المجلس المنحل يتكون من عده
مجموعات استشاريه تضم خبراء تطوعوا بوقتهم
لمعالجه قضايا بالغه الاهميه على المنصه
هؤلاء تحديدا يركزون على خصيه الامان بشكل
اساسي وكيف يمنعون المضايقات والانتحار
والاستغلال الجنسي للاطفال ببساطه انهم
معنيون بحقوق الانسان الرقميه ويضم اعضاء
المجلس المنحل شخصيات من منظمه جلاد
ومؤسسه حقوق الانسان سمر ريتانز والمركز
الوطني للاطفال المفقودين والمستغلين فكيف
لماسك بتحولاته هذه ان يجعلها تويتر ما
الاذان لحوريه التعبير وهو الذي تعهد بان
يجعلها هذا الامر او لوويته الاولى
وقراراته تظهر العكس فمن لم يستقل بنفسه
وسيقيله ماسك وهذا ما حدث حتى الاسبوع
الماضي قال ثلاثه من اعضاء المجلس الاسبوع
الماضي احتجاجا على تغييرات في المنصه
الاخيره مستشجرين في بيان بادله قالوا
انها تنظر الى ان سلامه ورفاهيه مستخدمات
وتر هي في تراجع
[موسيقى]
اذا البنتاجون في خبر عاجل يقول بان الجيش
الامريكي يستانف الدوريات مع قصد بعد
تعليقها بسبب الضربات التركيه الى صوره
اليوم وهي من الحدود بين صربيا والقسمه
وخلف هذه الصوره مشاهدينا انعكاس لمرض
الحرب بين البلدين بعد قيام محتجين الصرف
في شمال كسبوا باغلاق الطرق الرئيسيه
لليوم الثالث على التوالي اليوم وبعد
اشتعال فتيل الازمه من جديد تخشى اوروبا
من عوده الحرب الى البلقان مره اخرى لتعود
معها الاذهان الى حرب عام 1990
تصريح اليوم لرئيس الوزراء الهندي نارين
درامودي الذي حث دول العالم على الاعتراف
بقيمه نظام الطب التقليدي في بلاده
المعروف باسم ايرفيدا واعرب مدير خلال
مؤتمر عالمي عن الايور فيدا وقال انا سعيد
لان اكثر من 30 دوله قد اعترفت بهذا
النظام وهو نظام بديل بينما يرى الكثير من
الاطباء ان دعوته تفقر الى اسس علميه
راسخه
بدايه اليوم يعيدنا الى ايام اعتقدنا فيها
ان لا بديل عن الغاز في الشتاء حتى جاء
الوقت الذي اصبح فيه الغاز ثمينا فها هم
الالمان كما نشاهد في هذه الصور وجدوا
وسيله انسب للتدفئه مع ارتفاع اسعار الغاز
الطبيعي والكهرباء وعادي الاستخدام
المدافئ الحطب التي باتت اكثر شيوعا في
عصر الحرب الذي تحول بالنسبه للالمانيين
الى عصر الحطب ليجدوا بحرق الخشب دفئا
يغمروا منازلهم وربما وسيله اخرى يرتزقون
منها لقمه عيشهم فيقطعونها ويبيعونها
فالخشب ارخص بسته عشره مره مقارنه بالغاز
الذي كانوا يعتمدون عليه قبل الحرب
انتهت ملفاتنا لليوم شكرا على حسن
المتابعه والى زميله عادل عيدان واخبار
الساعه
ان شاء الله ننتظر مباراه كرواتيا
والارجنتين وهي الحدث الابرز في هذه
الساعه بالتاكيد وايضا لدينا في اسرائيل
مشروع يميني يعمل على توسيع الاستيطان
وغيرها من الاخبار شكرا